claudine année sont vernette avec nous
dans son crédit bonjour oui moi gérons
résultant bonjour et literie aux
auditrices et auditeurs de martinique
1ère merci d'être avec nous en ce jour
anniversaire du label aoc pour le rhum
agricole de martigues dont ce sera
demain
vous êtes la présidente du syndicat de
défense de l'appellation d'origine
remarie troll martinique depuis 10 ans
déjà la hausse et romaric hall martin
qui fait donc son 20e anniversaire une
haus aut valeur appeler madame naissons
vernant unique au monde
oui absolument marieville temps le rhum
martinique est le seul rom au monde à
avoir une appellation d'origine
contrôlée
il a été le premier par le décret du 5
novembre 1996 et donc comme vous l'avez
précisé c'est demain demain que le jour
j de l'anniversaire des 20 ans et à ce
jour il reste le seul homme à manaus et
c'est quand même une bizarre tu es un
devoir que n'est que la martinique qui
cette appellation d'origine contrôlée
mais et si vous voulez une appellation
d'origine contrôlée
une appellation d'origine contrôlée
si vous voulez est l'aboutissement d'une
démarche d'excellence contraignante mais
qui doit être une démarche volontariste
et collective et c'est ce que les
premiers martiniquais avait fait mener à
l'époque par jean pierre bourdilhan qui
était vraiment le capitaine de cette
demande et cette obtention n'a pas été
simple si vous voulez il a fallu 22 ans
d'un combat acharné pour que leurs
hommes martinique obtienne ce label mais
lorsqu'on voit les retombées aujourd'hui
ça n'a pas donné envie à d'autres
régions par exemple tout près de nous à
la loupe de faire pareil la guadeloupe a
choisi de une démarche que d'indications
géographiques
si vous voulez qui est beaucoup moins
contraignante que les cahiers des le
cahier des charges appliquée à
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée
martinique
c'est un choix bon eh bien nous allons
vous restez pas mort car tout encore
seules régions avec une appellation
d'origine contrôlée
est-ce que les martiniquais ressentent
ce label aoc est ce qu'ils envoient les
retombées je parle pas des de ceux qui
sont bons à cannes mais monsieur tout le
monde
est-ce qu'on en est fier est ce que on
se dit tiens c'est ça c'est beau caillou
soient écoutés oui j'ai l'impression
enfin avec avec le recule maintenant de
20 années j'ai vraiment l'impression que
le public martiniquais prend conscience
de ce label d'excellence et de ce que ça
représente en termes de potentialités
économiques pour la martinique
un d'eux mêmes les politiques également
mais bon peut être pas une prise de
conscience aussi importante qu'elle
devrait être
et qui ne se traduit peut-être pas dans
les faits c'est à dire par exemple nous
à nous avons si vous voulez nous avons
besoin de soutien économique surtout que
ce soit au plan de la martinique
au plan de la france et au plan de
l'europe et nous avons des soutiens de
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique
nous avons des soutiens de nos députés
et sénateurs nous avons des soutiens de
la france
mais si vous voulez actuellement au plan
européen nous avons nous avons des
difficultés une question de de
contingence de quota alors ça ça si vous
voulez le contingent c'est quelque chose
de franco français c'est une quantité de
rome qui est autorisé à l'export parce
que pour nous c'est de l'export en
france métropolitaine est le corollaire
est une fiscalité différentiel ou
privilégier si vous voulez qui dans le
but est d'essayer de compenser les
surcoûts de notre production par rapport
aux roms produits de par le monde alors
il ya des parlementaires comme celui de
saint-martin sénateur de saint martin
qui demandent justement que ces chiffres
que les quotas d'exportation soit revue
à la hausse tout à fait c'est quelque
chose qui ne peut se faire il faudrait
de combiers par exemple oui si vous
voulez ça peut se faire puisque nous
avons déjà
obtenu de passer de 90 mille hectolitres
d'alcool pur d'export à 120 milles mais
actuellement si vous voulez les
producteurs estiment que les producteurs
de rhums des dom estime que ce volume
est insuffisant et actuellement en
france métropolitaine qui est quand même
le grand marché d'export des roms les
parts de marché de nos roms diminue
encore par rapport par rapport à la
concurrence extérieure et qui pour nous
si vous voulez et quand même une conf
une concurrence déloyale entre
guillemets dans la mesure où les coûts
de production de ces roms sont
infiniment inférieurs aux nôtres
madame et son gouvernement pour bien
comprendre
on est fiers de notre aoc on vend notre
roms de plus en plus dans le monde à peu
près une centaine de pays qui qui
recherchent le rhum a haussé de
martinique mais en même temps sur le
marché français qui est le marché
naturel pour nous on est quand même en
difficulté à cause de la concurrence
internationale
oui mais pas seul pas seulement sur le
marché français sur aussi ce que nous
appelons le grand export puisque si vous
voulez 99% des roms produits dans le
monde sont des roms de mélasse c'est à
dire issu de la distillation de la
fabrication du sucre et qui ont un coût
de production infiniment inférieurs aux
nôtres bond de plus nous nous sommes
sous législation française et européenne
avec des obligations en termes de
charges sociales en termes de salaires
en termes d'obligations
environnementales qui sont infiniment
supérieur aux autres pays leur peugeot
sur ce label c'est ce qu'il faut si vous
voulez et c'est facile sinon c'est pas
c'est pas facile faisait pas facile si
vous voulez c'est assez
assez ambigu puisque de par le monde de
par le monde pendant les appellations
d'origine contrôlée française est un
signe reconnu connus et reconnus de
qualité puisqu'il a d'abord été connue
avec les grands vins avec les grands
spiritueux de france métropolitaine le
cognac l'armagnac et c'est donc si vous
voulez les quand les gens voient
appellation d'origine contrôlée pour eux
ces signes de qualité et signe de
traçabilité est ce que cette aoc est
régulièrement vérifier contrôler par des
experts qui viennent regarder comment ça
se passe et ce que distillerie quelle
qu'elle soit respecte toutes les règles
est ce que par exemple si on met une
cité à côté d'une plantation
ça peut peut-être influencé la
production de cette production
alors écoutez on est on est extrêmement
vérifier je puis vous l'assurer
à la fois en contrôle interne un par un
ingénieur du syndicat qui est le
correspondant de l'inao de l'institut
national des appellations d'origine et
on a un cahier de charges extrêmement
strictes que ce soit au plan agronomique
haut qu'au niveau du process
fermentation distillation maturation
vieillissement stockage mise en
bouteille étiquetage alors en plus de ce
contrôle interne permanent et rigoureux
on a ce qu'on appelle un contrôle
externe par un organisme certificateur
indépendant qui pour nous en martinique
et certipaq est-ce qu'on peut rester à
ce stade dao c'est avec les normes que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui est ce que
ce sont pas des règles qui risque de
changer ce qui est des enjeux
qualitatifs et quantitatifs qu'il faudra
peut-être qu'il faut voir venir déjà si
vous avez parfaitement raison si vous
voulez actuellement donc outre ce cahier
des charges
je dirais français ce qui concerne
l'appellation les appellations d'origine
contrôlée les roms sont soumis à un
règlement 110 2008 européen
c'est si vous voulez c'est un règlement
qui a été établi en 2008 donc avec des
contraintes qui nous sont imposées à
nous mais nous sommes très inquiets des
accords commerciaux qu'il y a que
l'europe passe avec divers pays parce
que les ces règles semblent s'appliquer
de façon beaucoup moins strictes à sérum
et nous nous estimons que c'est une une
concurrence déloyale donc ça se jouera à
bruxelles ainsi qu'à strasbourg
il faut être fier d'être martinique et
d'avoir ce rôle oui absolument alors moi
pour moi c'est une fierté que j'éprouve
depuis vingt ans et que je que je
continue à éprouver si vous voulez parce
que se sait vraiment ce rhum ce n'est
pas que ce n'est pas de l'alcool
si vous voulez c'est un produit
patrimoniale bon qui nous relie à notre
histoire à notre passé et on dit que les
distille appartiennent essentiellement à
des personnes qui ne sont pas
martiniquaise
ça c'est un point sur lequel je ne me
prononcerai pas mais si vous voulez le
il faut quand même reconnaître que le
passé en particulier dans la canne à
sucre appartient aux martiniquais et jeu
si vous voulez c'est pour moi très
intéressant de constater c'est un bon
exemple si vous voulez de résilience
puisque nous avons su nous descendants
de ceux qui ont survécu à la grande
traversée et aux travaux durs dans les
champs à la can l'audition nous avons su
le transcender et en faire un produit
dont nous pouvons être fiers et je pense
que c'est ça qui est ça la fierté
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
claudine naissant vernon on rappelle que
l'état président du syndicat de défense
de l'appellation d'origine rom
martinique demain l'anniversaire verte
pour cette aoc en martinique